Prof: So we're spending
a couple classes these days
learning basic facts and
vocabulary about finance,
and along the way we're trying
to apply the simple lessons that
Irving Fisher taught about
turning a financial problem into
a general equilibrium problem
and making use in particular of
the budget set.
That very simple budget set we
wrote down at the very beginning
turns out to be quite useful and
people often can get quite
confused.
So the last issue we ended
with, I'm going to take up
again.
Suppose that you've got a very
long-lived institution like
Yale.
How should Yale think of how
much to spend every year?
What is Yale's budget set?
Almost every big institution
like Yale creates a fiction of
an annual budget and they talk
about the deficit and having to
bring the deficit under control
and making cuts to close the
deficit gap,
but really there is no such
thing as a one-year budget set.
I mean, why one year?
Why not one month?
Why not one day?
Nobody expects Yale to balance
its budget every day.
Some expenditure comes in one
day.
They have to hire an
electrician to fix something
unexpected.
They're going to spend more
money than they take in student
tuition that day.
So the fact that they're
supposed to budget the balance
every year is just a fiction.
Irving Fisher taught us that
Yale really has--
if you can borrow and lend and
you don't have to worry about
risk there's one infinite-lived
budget set.
It's an infinite horizon budget
set where you just take the
present value of all the
expenditures,
that's the left hand side,
and the present value of all
the revenue,
that's the right hand side,
and make sure that the left
hand side is smaller than the
right hand side over the whole
course of Yale's life.
So that simple principle has a
tremendous implication which was
overlooked, to the chagrin of
the last Yale president.
So as I said,
the issue was in 1997,
I believe, it could have been
'96 something like that,
1997, Benno Schmidt,
who was then the Yale
president,
released a white paper,
he called it,
documenting the fact that Yale
had deferred maintenance in the
buildings,
he called it,
and a study that he
commissioned,
a very good study that he
argued that the deferred
maintenance--
Yale could be brought up to
snuff and then go on afterwards
as a normal running institution
provided it spent 100 million
dollars a year for ten years,
and that included fixing every
college--
they're going to do more than
one a year over a 10 year
period.
So Yale's total budget,
as I told you,
was about 1 billion dollars at
the time,
and then here all of a sudden
was this 100 million dollar a
year expense for 10 years.
That's 10 percent of the Yale
budget.
And a lot of the costs you
can't change.
You have to have the lights on.
You have to heat the buildings.
You can't really reduce those
costs.
So Benno Schmidt came to the
conclusion that he'd have to
reduce the costs he could change
by 15 percent in order to
balance the budget,
to cut about 100 million
dollars a year out of the
budget.
So he announced one day that he
was going to fire 15 percent of
the faculty by attrition.
If they were junior faculty he
wouldn't promote them,
and if they were senior
faculty, wait until they retired
and not replace them.
So this, needless to say,
caused a tremendous commotion
among the faculty,
and as I told you a committee
was formed and I had to present
the report.
So actually the report went
pretty carefully through all the
calculations made in the white
paper,
but the heart of the report was
simply to apply the lesson of
Irving Fisher.
So what is the lesson of Irving
Fisher?
Let's suppose that there's no
inflation so that when they say
100 million dollars a year they
mean 100 million real dollars a
year.
So Irving Fisher would say
Yale's going to live forever.
Let's suppose that Yale wants
the same quality of education
every year forever,
so it should have the same real
spending every year forever
after it compensates for
inflation.
So at the moment we're assuming
there's no inflation.
So what does that mean?
That means that you just look
at the right hand side and you
say, what's Yale's revenue?
Well, whatever it was before we
were told by this report of the
president that as long as you
did the deferred maintenance
Yale would be back in balance.
So what's the loss of revenue
on the right hand side?
It's 10 years of 100 million
dollars a year as you can see.
Now, you need an interest rate.
What should the interest rate
be?
Well, should it be the nominal
interest rate or the real
interest rate?
Well, we're supposing now
there's no inflation so it
should be the real interest rate
because all the hundreds have no
inflation in them.
So what real interest rate
shall we use?
Well, the white paper used 5
percent because they thought
that was the number that Yale
could earn after inflation
pretty reliably every year.
They think that's the real rate
of return Yale gets,
and so they discounted it 5
percent.
Now the real rate of interest
typically in the economy is 3
percent, but let's suppose that
we calculated this at 5 percent.
The present value of 100 for 10
years is 772.
Now, how could you do that in
your head?
Well, we know that 5 percent is
going to double every 14 years,
5 into 72 is about 14.
If it doubles every 14 years 10
years is going to be less than
half the value of the bond.
So if you got 100 forever at 5
percent interest that would be 2
billion,
and we know for only 10 years
it's less than half the value,
so considerably less than half
the value,
so it's not one billion it's
something less than that.
It's 772.
So I just did that in Excel and
I calculated 772,
but in your head you know that
if it had gone on for 14 years
then the present value,
our formula,
our famous formula is that you
would take the coupon 100
divided by the interest rate .05
times (1 - 1 over (1 R) to the
10th).
And so we know that if this
were 14 instead of 10 you'd get
a half here.
So this is 20 times 100 which
is 2 billion times 1 half would
be 1 billion,
but since it's only 10 years
and not 14 years it's less than
a billion,
so 772.
So in your head you could have
probably figured that out
approximately.
So you could be sitting there
in the audience hearing Benno
Schmidt talk and be computing in
your head that we're talking
about something under 1 billion,
like 3 quarters of 1 billion.
So now, how much does that mean
reduction in every year?
Well, if Yale's going to spend
the same amount every year that
means it should be spending 5
percent of 772 less every year.
That's 38.6 million dollars
less every year.
So that's a drastically smaller
number than 100 million dollars
a year.
It's crazy just to think that
because you've got these
expenditures for 10 years and
then no expenditures after that,
that you should cut the budget
by a 100 million and then let it
go up after 10 years.
So you'd only need to cut it by
38 million.
Now, by the way,
5 percent is a pretty arbitrary
number.
Suppose you put 3 percent here?
Well, 3 percent would give you
a much higher present value,
but then when you multiply it
by 3 percent at the end for the
annual reduction it will give
you a much smaller number.
Anyway, this number,
which I computed in Excel,
but again you can do it sort of
in your head,
is 853 million,
but you multiply that by 3
percent and you get 26 million a
year.
So now the reduction is
starting to sound like it's not
such a frightening thing.
So let's stick with the 5
percent which is what the white
paper,
take all the assumptions of the
white paper and take it
literally,
and then notice that they never
said anything about inflation.
So actually,
this calculation of present
value loss--there's inflation,
and say the inflation at that
time is around 4 percent.
In fact all the Yale contracts
that are still in place assume a
4 percent inflation even though
inflation's less than that now.
But anyway, so that 100 million
a year of dollars is actually
less in present value terms
because what should you discount
by?
If you look at the present
value of 100 million dollars
over 10 years and you take into
account its dollars you should
be discounting by the real
interest rate times the
inflation,
so by 9 percent,
a tiny bit over 9 percent.
So if you discount that by 9
percent you get 641 million as
the present value loss to Yale.
Now, given that there's
inflation how much should you be
spending every year?
You should be spending in real
dollars, reducing your
expenditure how much in real
dollars?
Well, by 5 percent of the 641
million.
So if you have 641,
that's today's present value.
There hasn't been any inflation
yet.
So that's the real loss in
dollars.
So if you ask,
what's the real expenditure
reduction every year,
it's 5 percent of 641 and
that's 32 million.
So 32 million is a far smaller
number than 100 million and
requires a far smaller drop in
expenses,
so our committee recommended
that we cut the faculty by 6
percent instead of by 15
percent,
and 6 percent--there are a lot
of people leaving every year.
You can do 6 percent pretty
quickly.
So the upshot of this is that
it is a simple application of
present value,
a very elementary calculation.
It came as somewhat of a
revelation to our
administrators,
I'm afraid, and the day after
the report the provost of the
university resigned.
Two weeks later the dean of the
university resigned and two
months later the president of
the university resigned.
And Rick Levin,
the current president,
took over and he cut the
faculty by 6 percent,
but by no more than that.
And then, of course,
the finances of Yale got much
better and he's since added back
that 6 percent plus a little bit
more than that.
So just to tell you,
though, something good about
the Yale administration,
the provost who resigned that
next day happens to be a friend
of mine.
I've had dinner with him every
month for the last 12 years
since this happened and he's
never once criticized me or
shown the slightest discomfort
about the report that basically
ended his administrative career.
He cares so much about Yale and
was so determined to do the
right thing.
He just thought he made a
miscalculation and stepped
aside.
So I believe that he wanted to
do the right thing for Yale and
just made the wrong calculation,
not that he had some political
agenda or something to cut such
a huge part of the faculty.
So it's the most honest and
most Yale-loving administrator
that you could imagine.
And I didn't know what the
reaction would be of someone
like him after giving the
report.
I was quite terrified,
actually, that they'd be--
they were still the president,
the provost and the dean,
that they would be quite angry
at our committee,
but they responded with
tremendous integrity.
Yes?
Student: Why did you
multiply the present value by
the interest rate to find the
>?
Prof: You tell me.
Why did I do that?
So someone else tell me.
So that's a good question.
Why is that?
Yes?
Student: It's like
finding the coupon of the
perpetuity with a 5 percent
interest rate,
because it's like you're
rearranging C over r equals the
present value,
so it'd make it present value
times the interest rate equals
C.
Prof: Right.
So the question was why,
after I figured out the present
value loss like 772 million,
why did I multiply that by 5
percent to figure out how much
Yale should reduce its spending
every year.
And the answer that was given
down here is that I'm assuming
that Yale is going to go on
forever.
So Yale can reduce its
expenditures every year forever
and by doing that make up for
the same present value loss,
so forever means perpetually,
so it's a perpetuity.
So how much do you have to
reduce--
what is the coupon reduction,
the expenditure reduction every
year at 5 percent interest that
just makes a present value
decline of 772 million?
Well, it's 5 percent of the
principal.
If you have 772 million in the
bank and every year 5 percent of
that you throw away,
you've thrown away the whole
value,
at 5 percent interest,
of the 772 million.
So by reducing your
expenditures by 5 percent every
year you defray the 772 million
dollar loss.
So the critical thing,
the critical mistake that the
administration made is they had
a short run problem with a bunch
of short run costs,
but Yale's going to live
forever and Yale should share
the cost and the loss over all
future generations,
not just make the current
faculty, and the current
students,
and the current city bear all
the costs of this one shot loss,
one shot problem that Yale
faced.
So they weren't thinking in
Fisher's terms of taking the
present value over the whole
course of the lifetime of the
institution.
They were thinking,
well, we've got to spend 100
million dollars this year we
better cut costs by 100 million
dollars.
But that's obviously crazy.
Like suppose you had to spend
an extra 100,000 dollars in one
day.
Does that mean you should lay
off your faculty for one day so
you can find the money to pay
that?
And of course not,
so you have to spread the loss
over the lifetime of the
university.
Are there any other questions
about this principle?
Yes?
Student: If you wanted
to return to say spending 100
million dollars a year again
after 10 years would you spend
77 million a year for those just
10 years if you wanted to incur
the whole cost over a fixed
period of time?
Prof: If I wanted to
incur the whole cost over 10
years?
Student: Yes.
Prof: Then I would have
to reduce my expenditures by 100
million dollars a year.
If at the end of 10 years I
wanted to be back even then I
would have to spend less.
I would have to cut my
expenditures by exactly the
money I was pouring into the
buildings.
So if I wanted to reduce my
expenditures by an equal amount
every year it would have to be
100 million dollars for 10
years, right?
If the maintenance costs go
over a 10-year period and I want
the expenditures to go over a
10-year period,
right?
So if I want the expenditures
to be reduced evenly over a
10-year period I'd have to do
100 million dollars a year.
If I wanted to eat away the
costs all in 1 year--I guess I
didn't understand you're
question.
You're saying if I wanted to
reduce expenditures entirely in
1 year and then return next year
to my usual pattern of
expenditure then I'd have to cut
the 1 billion dollar budget by
772 million.
So that would involve basically
firing the whole faculty and
saying take a year off you're on
furlough, sort of what they're
doing in California.
Yes?
Student: Can you also
spread the present value cost
evenly over 10 years and not
like 100 million dollars every
year,
but 100 million in present
value terms.
Prof: I could do that if
I wanted.
I could rearrange the 100
million any way I wanted to.
So you would cut less than 100
million dollars this year out of
the budget and a little bit more
every year after that?
Student: Assuming you
wanted to get these costs over
with in a 10-year timeframe.
Prof: Well,
one way to do the costs over
with in a 10-year timeframe is
reduce costs,
reduce paying the faculty by
100 million dollars every year
for 10 years,
right?
That would obviously do it,
because that's the money I need
to get.
You could now rearrange that by
reducing costs a little less at
the beginning and a little more
at the end of the 10 years,
but I would say that doesn't
sound--
why do that?
That's kind of what bad
politicians do.
They say, "It's not our
fault.
We'll just make those guys in
year 10 get totally
crushed,"
and pretty soon they are in
year 10 and then they've got 200
million they have to cut costs.
Yes?
Student: So say in 25
years Yale wants to do another
round of rebuilding all of the
buildings they'll still be
paying for the buildings that
they built 25 years prior?
Prof: Right.
So there's a good question.
So actually some people,
the administration,
that was their best response,
they said,
"Well even though the
white paper said this was a one
shot thing,
and after we do this 10 year
plan Yale is back in good shape,
and of course every year Yale
has allowed maintenance
expenses.
That's part of the budget is
maintenance.
So after we get the buildings
back in tip top shape we're
going to keep them in tip top
shape by doing these normal
expenditures every year so we
should never have another period
where you have to do something
drastic like that."
That's what the white paper
said, but after the report they
responded just like you said.
They said, "Well,
we didn't really mean that.
Maybe in 25 years we're going
to have to do another remodeling
effort."
And so well,
if you need to that then it
wasn't just a one-time deferred
maintenance.
It means that you've
drastically underestimated the
cost of keeping up the buildings
over Yale's whole future,
so then you would have these
reductions in expenditures for
the first 10 years and then in
year 35 you'd have to have more
reductions,
and then in year 70 you'd have
more reductions like that.
So you have to take the present
value of all those things and
then figure out how much to
reduce expenditures on an even
basis and so it would be much
more than 32 million.
It would be 60 or something
million or 50 million.
So you're exactly right,
but that's not what they said
in the white paper.
So I took them literally what
they meant.
So what happened after that?
Yale has done much more
building expenditures than that,
but that's because Yale's
endowment went up to 23 billion.
So from 3 billion which it was
at the time it's now 23 billion
so Yale's launched an incredible
program of building
construction.
Basically they've done two
things.
They've built a huge number of
construction jobs and they've
hired a lot of administrators
and stuff.
So the faculty is still not
that much bigger.
It went down 6 percent.
It's now back a little bigger
than it was before.
So the plan to expand the
college and expand the faculty
hasn't happened yet.
So Yale faces another choice
now.
You know the endowment went to
23 billion and then this past
year they managed to lose down
to 17 billion,
30 percent got lost.
So we're down to 17 billion now.
So again we have the same
question.
We just lost 6 billion dollars.
How much should we reduce
expenditures every year?
So what's your answer to that?
Student: About 30
percent?
Prof: Not 30 percent.
So how much would you reduce
expenditures?
Why wouldn't it be 30 percent?
Because Yale spends a lot of
money it doesn't get from the
endowment, right?
It gets money from tuition,
for example.
So what should Yale do?
What do you think Yale's going
to have to take out of the
budget now?
Student:
>
calculation.
Prof: Yeah,
and let's say it's still 5
percent real interest then what
would you do?
Student: Present value's
6 billion dollars and we assume
we're at 5 percent interest.
Prof: Yeah,
so what's that?
Student: 6 over .05?
Prof: 6 times .05,
so what's that?
Hard to do these things in your
head, right, but what is it?
Student: 300 million.
Prof: 300 million,
so Yale's got to somehow cut
300 million out of its budget so
it's not going to do it in one
year,
but over the course of the next
few years it's going to have to
cut 300 million.
Now the budget is well over 2
billion so that's 15 percent of
the budget, though,
Yale's going to have to cut.
So this is a serious thing.
How do you cut 15 percent of
the Yale budget?
Student: Firing faculty.
Prof: Firing faculty,
well, I hope they don't do
that.
I think they learned their
lesson so I doubt if they'll do
that.
Things are already changing.
They're charging for long
distance telephone calls and all
kinds of stuff like that.
That doesn't get you quite 300
million, but there's going to be
a bunch of stuff like that.
So anyway, we have another
budget problem,
by the way.
So these kinds of budget
problems are happening all over
the country.
I gave a talk at Albany
University and they're going to
abolish their graduate economics
program, SUNY Albany.
These are serious problems
losing that much money.
But in any case 6 billion
translates to,
right, the difference here is 6
billion and you multiply that by
.05 just as we said and that
equals 300 million a year.
So Yale won't do it right away,
but over the course of a few
years Yale's going to have to
reduce its budget by 300
million,
so they're going to obviously
choose to do a lot less building
and presumably some of the new
people that got hired they're
going to not keep.
So any other questions?
Yep?
Student: Doesn't that
presume that the endowment stays
that way?
Prof: Yes.
Student: Could you also,
once the stock market and the
real estate goes back up,
can you have some assumption
that they don't need to cut as
much?
Prof: Right,
very good question.
So in the front he's saying
this presumes that we know for
sure that the endowment lost 6
billion.
It'll never recover it.
Maybe that's a temporary drop
in the stock market and it'll go
back up,
and basically the principle
he's applying is he's saying you
can't make these drastic
reductions in annual
expenditures,
firing people and then two
years later realizing you've got
a lot of money trying to hire
them back because you won't be
able to hire them back.
So clearly Yale has to have a
more complicated rule about how
it gradually adjusts its
spending when there's a change
in the endowment.
And so we're going to talk
about that later because it
involves uncertainty and how to
think about uncertainty.
But you're absolutely right.
So Levin did not announce a 300
million dollar reduction
immediately,
but he announced a big
reduction immediately,
and you're going to expect next
year if the stock market doesn't
drastically improve for there to
be another reduction.
And, by the way,
this number could go down as
well as it goes up.
So we're going to come back to
Yale's investments and what
they're like.
A lot of Yale's investments are
called private equity
investments that are very hard
to value.
So for all we know this 17 is a
lot worse than that,
but we'll be finding out in the
next year or two.
It's not like a hedge fund
where you have to value all your
assets by what the market will
be willing to pay.
A lot of these assets there is
no market so they just sort of
make up what the number is.
Anyway, we're going to come
back and discuss this.
It's a very interesting
question.
So one last thing about this
present value calculation,
one last obvious thing,
it's hard to keep in your mind
the difference between real and
nominal.
So let's just do a very simple
thing.
The mortgage,
mortgages are traditionally
nominal fixed payments.
So for example,
a 100,000 dollar 30 year
mortgage at 2.3 percent is about
4,600 dollars per year.
How did I do that so quickly in
my head?
Well, because I know if the
interest rate is 2.3 percent and
you're going to pay it forever
you'd pay 2,300 a year.
We know at 30 years at 2.3
percent, 2.3 percent doubles
almost in 30 years.
That's 69.
That's getting pretty close to
72, so maybe it takes 31 years
or something to double.
So after 30 years the remainder
is worth half the mortgage.
So you've lost half of the
value by only getting it for 30
years.
So instead of paying 2,300 you
have to pay 4,600.
So the coupon over .023 times
(1 - 1 over 1.023 to the
thirtieth),
that's 1 - 1 half about,
so if this coupon equals
100,000 the payment is going to
be--
since this is 1 half the
payment isn't going to be 2,300.
It has to be twice that, 4,600.
So it's 4,600 per year.
So if there's no inflation that
means you're making the same
real payment every year.
Now what happens if there's
inflation?
What if inflation goes up?
Now what's going to happen to
what you have to pay?
How would you figure that out?
Well, if inflation is another
2.3 percent or something,
then the nominal interest rate
1 i is going to equal the real
interest rate times the rate of
inflation.
So let's say this is 1.023 and
this is also 1.023,
so that's 1.046,
a little bit more than 4 6,
almost a little bit more than 4
6.
So you know that the interest
rate the mortgage companies are
now going to charge is going to
be 1.046.
So the 4.6 is going to be the
mortgage interest rate and so
you can figure out by the same
calculation what the coupon's
going to be.
So what's the coupon going to
be?
Well, instead of doubling every
30 years at 4.6 percent it's
going to double approximately
every 15 years.
So this is going to be doubling
twice.
This is 1 quarter,
so this'll be 3 quarters here.
And so if you multiply
everything, 2,300 a year times 4
thirds--am I doing the right
calculation here?
I'm telling you it's so easy to
compute in your head and
meanwhile.
Oh, I forgot to change this to
4 6, so the interest rate is 4
6.
So this to the other side is
4,600 times 4 thirds and that's
6,000 about.
So the annual payment is going
to go up to 6,000 instead of
4,600.
It was 4,600.
The interest rate went up
because there was inflation,
so of course they're going to
ask you for more money every
year,
because if you pay the same
amount every year and this is
the real payment--
if you make the same amount and
this is time in terms of
inflation corrected dollars
you're paying less and less
every year.
So clearly if you started with
no inflation and a number like
this,
so no inflation and now you've
got inflation but the same real
interest rate,
and the present value of your
expenditures,
the real present value,
right--the mortgage company's
going to want,
the lender's going to want to
get the same amount back in real
terms as it got before because
the inflation hasn't changed the
real world.
So Irving Fisher would say the
inflation is just a veil.
Everybody's going to want the
same real interest rate and so
the mortgage is going to have to
return the same real thing it
did before.
The present value in real
terms, or the real payments is
still going to be 100,000.
So if the real payments go down
over time and have the same
present value they had before
it's got to be that they're
higher at the beginning and in
real terms lower at the end.
So sure enough 6,000 is a much
higher number at the beginning
than 4,600.
So of course when inflation
went up and everybody knows it's
up the mortgage companies are
going to ask for higher annual
payments so it'd be 6,000 a year
instead of 4,600 a year.
But now if you inflation
correct that,
the 6,000 every year is going
to be less,
in terms of real goods,
less and less every year,
but the present discounted
value of this thing has to be
the same as where you started.
So the effect is the young
borrowers are going to be
spending a lot more in real
goods when they're young and a
lot less when they're old.
So inflation has an unfortunate
impact on mortgages quoted in
nominal dollars that it makes
the repayments happen earlier.
So the young who have less
money are having to pay a huge
amount,
and when they get old the
inflation's so high that that
same 6,000 dollars is
practically nothing.
So when they're 50 and 60
they're paying
practically--they're peanuts to
them, but when they were young
it was really a hardship.
So there's a big problem with
nominal mortgages,
which is that in inflationary
times it kills the housing
market.
Fortunately we're not in
inflationary times.
Any questions about that?
All right, so that's the basic
lesson of taking the present
value.
And again, you've always got to
sort out the nominal from the
real,
and look though the veil,
and don't get all mixed up by
the fact that there's inflation.
It's the real thing that you
want to concentrate on as much
as you can.
So that's it for the obvious
lesson of present value.
Now I want to introduce another
word which is very famous in
finance.
It's called the yield or yield
to maturity.
And I'm going to do it,
unlike the way I've presented
in the notes,
I'm going to do it in terms of
a hedge fund,
so if you can see this?
So yield, the next topic,
or yield to maturity is a way
of trying to compute one number
that summarizes how good a bond
is,
or how good,
how well a hedge fund has done.
So I think the more interesting
case, and the less obvious one,
is to start with a hedge fund.
How do you measure how well a
hedge fund's doing or how well
it's done in the past?
Yeah, how well it's done in the
past.
We're going to spend a lot of
the course talking about this in
various ways,
but the first way to do it
involves yield to maturity.
So let's see why the problem is
a little complicated.
So I imagine that there are
three investors in this hedge
fund.
So every year some of the
investors are going to decide
what to do, and they're going to
decide whether to withdraw
money.
Here's investor one.
Maybe he's going to withdraw
money.
The hedge fund's just beginning.
He's going to put in 100
dollars.
The other two guys haven't done
anything.
So now the hedge fund before
this guy put in his money had
nothing.
It's just beginning.
He's put in his 100 dollars,
so the hedge fund's got 100
dollars.
So that's it.
So I'm imagining these all
happen, they usually happen
quarterly or annually or
something.
They don't happen every day.
There's a fixed moment at which
everyone deposits their money.
So let's say they happen
annually.
The guy puts in 100 dollars at
the beginning of the year.
For the rest of the year nobody
can do anything.
They can't take money out.
They can't put money in.
So the hedge fund,
let's say, manages to put the
100 dollars to work and finds a
7 percent return.
So it's now got,
the hedge fund all together has
got 107 dollars.
So let's just go to the hedge
fund all together.
The hedge fund had 100 after
these guys, because only one guy
put in money and now the hedge
fund's got 107 dollars.
Well, that 107 dollars is all
the first guy's money,
because nobody else has put
anything in.
He still owns it.
So, so far the hedge fund got a
7 percent return.
Well, now the next year,
we're now at the beginning of
year 2,
our first investor thinks to
himself,
"Well, they did fine,
7 percent, not great,
but I'm okay.
I'm not going to do anything,
won't take any money out or put
any in.
A rich second investor puts in
1,000 and another guy puts in
200.
So now what's happened to the
NAV of the fund?
Well, the first guy,
at the moment they put in the
money, the first guy still owns
107 of the dollars.
The second guy's now got 1,000
in the fund and the third guy's
got 200 in the fund and the
hedge fund now has 1,200 plus
the 107.
That's 1,307.
That's how much money is in the
fund.
So that's at the beginning of
year 2 if you're still following
this.
If you're not following it
interrupt me.
Sorry.
So what happens in the
beginning of the next year,
year 3, well let's say our
guy--so the hedge fund makes
money and this time it made 3
percent,
a crappier, sorry,
a less good return,
only 3 percent.
God, it's on film.
I'm glad that's going to live
for posterity.
Only a 3 percent return,
and so the hedge fund which
ended the year at 1,307 now by
the next of this next year it's
made 3 percent on that so it's
up to 1,346,
so 39 dollars,
3 percent on 1,300 so 1,346.
Now of that who's got the money?
Well, our original guy he's now
made--everyone made 3 percent so
his 107 turned into 110.
The second guy's got 1,030 in
the fund,
and the third guy's got 206 in
the fund and the total fund is
1,346,
Now let's suppose that our guy,
this is the beginning of year
3,
our first guy says,
"3 percent,
that's a terrible return.
I'm taking my money out.
I've had it.
It's 110 dollars.
That's what I have.
I'm taking it out,"
and no one else does anything.
So at the end of the year now
he's down to zero and everybody
else is where they were and the
hedge fund thing has gone down a
little bit.
Well now next year the thing
does even worse.
It makes a 0 percent return.
So everybody's money is just
the same except that the second
guy decides this is really
getting lousy and he takes half
his money out.
So this is taking half his
money out.
What was his money?
He was 1,112 and half of that
is 556.
So he takes half of it out
leaving half behind,
and the column on the right
reduces what the hedge fund's
total cash is.
But now the hedge fund has a
great year and it makes 50
percent.
Having made 50 percent--sorry,
so this guy takes half his
money out.
At the beginning of the year
the fund does badly then the
fund--I skipped the 8 percent.
There was an 8 percent return,
sorry.
Oh, what an idiot.
Anyway, so the next year the
fund returned not 0 percent it
returned 8 percent.
So the first guy after the 3
percent return this guy took his
money out.
The other guys left it in and
then the fund had an 8 percent
return.
So it's a little bit better,
but this guy decides to take
half his money out.
Then the fund has a 0 percent
return and after that this guy
decides to take his money out,
half his money out,
but then finally the last year
the fund gives a 50 percent
return,
which is fantastic,
so everybody does well.
And now let's say they all
decide to take their money out.
So now there's nothing left in
the fund, and they withdrew the
total 934.
So what I've done here,
just to summarize it,
is every year people are
putting in money or taking out
money at the beginning of the
year.
You can never take out more
than you have or you can put
money in.
The fund earns returns over the
whole year and then people,
again, decide to take money out
or put money in and then the
fund earns a different return
the next year,
and eventually the fund returns
all the money or people withdraw
the money.
So the question is how has the
fund done?
How would you summarize in one
number how the fund has done
over its 1,2,
3,4, 5 years of earning
returns?
That's the question.
So this is a standard--this is
obviously what happens every day
with hedge funds.
So how do hedge funds report
how they've done historically?
So do you have any suggestions?
What would you do to summarize
how the hedge fund has done?
If you had to pick one number
what would it be?
How good an investor is the
fund?
Yeah?
Student: Just multiply
the return.
Take a geometric average.
Prof: So one thing you
could do is you could say--he
said literally multiply all of
these returns.
What does that mean?
That means if you put 1 dollar
in the fund at the beginning
you'd earn 7 percent.
If you left it there and never
took it out you get another 3
percent.
Then you'd get 8 percent on top
of that, then 0 percent,
then 50 percent.
Of course this is a
multiplicative thing,
so he says you'd get 1.07 times
1.03 times 1.08 times 1 times
1.5.
Multiplying all that would give
you the number of dollars you'd
have at the end of 5 years given
that you put 1 dollar in at the
beginning and never took it out.
And if you wanted to annualize
that he said take the geometric
average,
the fifth root of that and
that's the constant rate of
return that would have given you
the same amount of money at the
end that you would get by having
left 1 dollar from the beginning
in the fund all the way to the
end.
Is that clear to everybody?
That seems like a logical thing
to do.
That's what money hedge funds
do do, in fact.
That's the number they tell you.
Now, why might not that be a
great number?
Did everyone follow what his
suggestion was?
So by the way,
his number's going to come out
to be--well, I don't know.
Anyway it's going to be some
number.
We could do that.
In fact it wouldn't be that
hard to do.
Let's just do it.
Sum, oh this wasn't a very--ah!
How about equals?
Oh, dear, all right,
circular reference.
Equals sum.
Oh, why did I get zero here?
Oh, because I'm trying to
multiply these.
I'm adding instead, so equals.
I'll just have to do it one by
one.
That times the next one,
times the next one.
There's obviously a much faster
way of doing this.
Times the next one,
times that one and zero,
that's what 1 dollar would have
gotten you if you had put it in
and kept it until the end,
and now he's saying take this
to the fifth power.
So I'll take up this .2 enter.
So 12.2 percent,
now why isn't that the right
number?
Why might you think there
should be another number?
What's another number?
What's the matter with
that--way back there?
Student: It's grossly
inflated by that last year's 50
percent return.
Prof: Well,
is it grossly inflated,
but why is it grossly inflated
by that?
Student: There are going
to be lots of years where it
doesn't do that.
Prof: That's true,
but you've taken that into
account.
So the years we didn't do that
well like the 0 percent return
that brought the average down,
so why is that a problem
exactly?
Yeah, it's averaging the good
years with the bad years,
so.
Yeah?
Student: As far as a
measure of past performance it
doesn't take into account that
after three mediocre years a lot
of money was removed from the
fund.
Prof: That's the crucial
thing.
So I didn't do extreme enough
numbers.
The crucial thing to take into
account is that suppose you have
a fund that starts off,
many funds like my fund started
off with very little money,
but we did it at the right time
because we knew that was a good
time.
You're going to see when the
leverage cycle,
we talk about it.
It was at the bottom of the
leverage cycle just like this
past year.
We're up 30 percent this year.
So at the bottom of the
leverage cycle you're going to
have a great year.
Of course we hardly had any
money because the fund was just
starting, and so we made 50
percent the first year.
But then everybody said,
"Oh,
these guys must be
geniuses,"
and they poured a huge amount
of money into our fund,
and let's say the next year we
did 10 percent.
Actually we had another great
year the second year,
but let's say that we did 10
percent the second year.
So the young man in the front
is saying you made 50 percent on
pennies and then you made 10
percent on a gigantic amount of
money.
It isn't right to take the
average of 50 percent and 10
percent because almost all the
money that you managed you made
10 percent on not 50 percent on.
That's his point.
So how would you deal with his
point?
How could you figure out a way
of computing the right return to
compensate for the fact that
some years you have a lot more
money at stake than you have
other years?
Yes?
Student: Take a weighted
average?
Prof: Take a weighted
average.
Well, how would you take the
weighted average?
Sounds a little complicated.
That's what I'm going to do,
but it's not immediately
obvious how to do it.
So I wouldn't have expected you
to be able to answer that.
You're right on the right track.
So does anyone have anything
else to say?
Yep?
Student: I guess you
multiply each
>
, and then you add it all up
and divide it by the
>
Prof: All right,
so I'm going to now give you
the answer which is a little bit
like that.
She's saying do some dollar
weighted thing,
and so you somehow weight the
numbers by how much money there
was invested for that year.
So because there was a lot more
money invested in year 3 than
there was in year 1 that number
should somehow have a bigger
weight.
And it's not exactly clear how
the weights are going to get in
there, but it's obvious that
that's something like that you
ought to do.
So here's the mathematical
solution that the internal rate
of return or yield gives.
So it says every year let's
look at what happened in the
fund.
We shouldn't care about which
investor put in which dollar.
We care about how the fund
managed dollars.
The names of the investors
don't make any difference.
It's how did the fund manage
its money.
So in the first year the fund
got 100 dollars.
So as for producing money it
produced a negative 100.
Money went into the fund.
That was the one guy invested.
We don't care who it was.
The total that went into the
fund was 100.
The second year 1,200 went into
the fund.
Those are the second two guys.
The third year 110 came out.
That was the first guy.
The fourth year 556 came out.
That was the second guy.
This is beginning of the fifth
year.
The third guy took out 155
dollars, and then the last year
the second and third guys took
out everything that was left.
So from the point of view of
money creation and use this is
every year what went into the
fund and what came out of the
fund, the net inflow out.
So there are a bunch of numbers.
So the question is,
so the one number summary is
what rate of return,
it's called the internal rate
of return which if you
discounted all these numbers
what would Fisher say if you
discounted all these numbers?
If you had to use just one
interest rate,
Fisher would say,
what's the present value of
these cash flows?
Well, if the interest rate was
0 you just add up all the
numbers and you're going to get
a big positive.
If the interest rate is
infinity then that means that
after the first year you're
discounting everything to 0 and
you're going to get negative
100.
So you could say,
what interest rate could you
discount all the cash flows at
to produce 0?
That would be like saying at
that interest rate,
all the fund has done is
rearranged its money.
It's taken money in and put
money out, but at that same
constant interest rate the
present value is 0.
So it's allowed you to trade
money across periods at this
internal rate of return,
the interest rate which makes
the present value zero.
So 10 percent turns out to be
the right number.
So if you discounted things by
10 percent,
you see what the formula is,
you take the inflow and you
discount it by 1.10 to the first
power and this you discount by
1.10 to the second power,
the inflow, the net outflow,
I guess,
which is 110 you discount by
1.10 to the third power
etcetera.
You keep discounting by that
and you get all the discounted
net flows.
You add them all up and you get
practically nothing.
That's adding them up and this
is taking the square,
and I used Solver to figure out
what the right discount rate was
to make all this zero.
So that's the simple way of
averaging, dollar weighting
everything.
You don't care about who the
people are.
You don't care about whether
one guy's putting money in,
another guy's taking it out at
the same time.
You just care about the net,
and if you've got a bunch of
net numbers,
that's the net outflow,
and you're trying to say,
what's the single rate of
return?
The idea is to say at what
interest rate?
If there were a bank paying an
interest rate and all those
things discounted gave you zero
that would be like saying the
fund is functioning just like a
bank.
No matter when people put the
money in or take it out they're
always getting this rate of
return which is 10 percent.
So they're getting a constant
10 percent rate of return no
matter when the money goes in or
out and that kind of gives you a
measure of how well the fund's
doing.
So that's the internal rate of
return, or the yield to
maturity.
It says take the net cash flows
every year.
Find the number which when you
discount at that number you get
present value equal to zero.
So it's 10 percent which is a
different number from 12
percent.
Now before we got the geometric
average of 12 percent.
Now very typically this is the
case that this internal rate of
return is lower than the dollar
return from putting the money in
at the beginning,
assuming the fund doesn't just
collapse and go to zero at the
end.
So why is that?
For funds that have survived
typically that number,
12 percent, is higher than 10
percent.
Why would that be?
What does that tell you about
the world?
Someone who hasn't--well,
go ahead.
Student: That it's
easier to make money with a
smaller amount of money?
Prof: It tells you that,
and how is it that the hedge
fund--it could tell you that.
It tells you that the hedge
funds are doing better when they
have a smaller amount of money
than when they have a larger
amount of money,
exactly.
You've concluded that it's
easier to make money when you
have a small amount.
What's another possible
explanation?
Student: People normally
invest a lot after a big year
>
Prof: Right.
I think that's the reason.
The reason is that people pour
money into hedge funds just
after they've done incredibly
well,
and they keep pouring money in,
then eventually there's a blow
up.
And so when the blow up comes
the hedge funds have zillions of
dollars and they're losing a lot
of money.
Then everybody pulls their
money out and that's when the
cycle is going up and then all
of a sudden the hedge funds have
these huge returns again,
but they hardly have any money.
So, any other questions about
this?
All right, so internal rate of
return is a way--
we are going to see that it has
many shortcomings,
but it's a way at getting at
the idea,
as several of you have said,
that you can't just take the
geometric average,
which is what every hedge fund
like ours always produces.
That's the number we tell
everybody because it's a better
number than the other one.
So the geometric average of the
returns are,
if you're an investor who puts
1 dollar in at the beginning and
leaves it there forever what's
your geometric average of all
your returns.
That's not a good reflection of
how the hedge fund's done
necessarily because some years
the fund had a lot of money to
work with.
And so the average dollar
didn't do that well,
and now there's a question
about how should you measure the
average dollar,
and I've given the internal
rate of return.
There are actually other
formulas you could give.
This is the most famous one.
Now let's see how this internal
rate of return is used all the
time on Wall Street.
By the way, if you're not
following what I'm saying you
should please interrupt me.
So what if you took a bond,
a simple coupon bond?
What is a simple coupon bond?
The yield to maturity of a
simple coupon bond,
I'm now on this lecture called
yield, what is a simple coupon
bond?
A simple coupon bond pays the
same coupon every year and then
pays the principal and the
coupon at its maturity.
So the yield to maturity is
going to be the price,
which is like a negative
payment--suppose you knew the
price of this bond.
If you knew the price of the
bond, and so the bond is
promising all these payments,
how good a deal is that?
Well, how good a deal it is
they would say is you simply
take this first negative payment
and all these positive payments
and find the unique interest
rate which when you discount it
will give you present value of
0.
And so if this is a coupon
bond, say paying 7 percent,
say the face is 100,
it pays 7 dollars forever,
and 107 at the end,
and the price is 105,
what do you think the yield to
maturity is going to be?
Can you say anything
qualitative about it?
Suppose it's a 7 percent coupon
bond, face of 100,10-year bond,
no one thinks that it'll
default, but its price is 105.
What is the yield to maturity
in that case do you suppose?
Just a vague guess,
I just want a qualitative
number.
Student: 6.7?
Prof: 6.7,
that's qualitatively wrong.
Well, I mean it's not
qualitatively wrong.
No, it's qualitatively right.
It could have been better.
So he's right.
So what if the price were 100
what would the yield to maturity
be?
Student: 7 percent.
Prof: 7 percent,
that's obvious,
right?
If it's a 7 percent coupon bond
on face of 100 and its price is
100,
price = to the face,
then obviously the thing that
discounts you back to 100 is
going to be 7 percent interest.
So if the price were 100 the
yield to maturity would just be
7 percent.
But I told you the price was
105, which is a lot more
expensive.
So it's a bad deal.
So it's not going to be as good
as 107.
So it's not going to be 7
percent and he said 6.7.
So I think it would be a little
worse than that,
but that's qualitatively just
what I asked for,
something worse than 7 percent.
So who said 6.7 percent?
You did.
Student: I just took the
price of the bond over the
coupon payment and that's 6.7,
but it's not the only
>
Prof: So that's another
number.
So I'm going to come back to
your question.
It's a good question.
So do you all see that if you
measured the yield to maturity
on this bond--so the bond,
remember, pays 7,7,
7,107 and its price is 105.
So the yield to maturity is
going to be that number such
that 105 = 7 over (1 the yield)
7 over (1 the yield) squared 7
over (1 the yield) cubed ...
107 over (1 yield) to the
tenth, that's 105.
So what we observed is that Y
has to be less than 7 percent
because if Y were exactly equal
to 7 percent this would give us
100.
But this bond is more
expensive, so you're paying more
to get the same payments you
would--than the face.
You're paying more than the
face to get the same payment.
If the price were equal to the
face it would be a 7 percent
yield.
So since you're paying more
you're getting a worse deal,
so it's pretty obvious that if
you want to discount this number
to more than 100,
namely 105, Y is going to have
to be less than 7 percent.
So that's the first thing we
said.
Now what did he do?
He gave a number and he said 7
over 105 which he said was about
6.7 percent.
So that number that he gave is
called the current yield.
It's another number people
give, and he figured that was
6.7 percent.
So let's believe him that's 6.7
percent.
How does that number compare to
the yield to maturity,
to Y?
Well, we could compute this out
on Excel since I'm doing so
brilliantly at it now.
So we could go 7,7,
7,7, 7,7, 7,7,
7, and 107.
Those are our payments and then
we could try some yield to
maturity, internal rate of
return and let's guess 1.067.
And now we'd say the cash flow
is going to be this,
is going to be the left.
Oh dear, I have to number
things.
So again, there's probably some
clever way of doing this.
So this'll be--I forgot to
write the year.
Let's just add this.
Equals up 1 enter.
So I'm just going to copy this.
All right, so now I've numbered
all the years.
Equals up 1 enter and now
control copy.
So I've numbered all the years
here and here are the payments.
And now at this yield to
maturity I'm going to go equal
the thing on the left divided by
the yield to maturity that we're
guessing raised to this power.
Now I can just copy that and
I've got all these cash flows.
Oh, what did I do that time?
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: What?
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: Control copy,
sorry.
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: Control copy,
right?
So I just want to copy this?
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: Oh, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
right, right,
right, so here I've got
the--you are right.
So there's a trick here which I
forgot which is the discount
rate,
the internal rate of return E
I've got to put a dollar sign,
dollar E, dollar 1 so that way
it remembers the spot.
So now when I copy it it's
going to remember that.
Student: B1.
Prof: What's B1?
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: Oh, B1.
Thank you, so there are two
mistakes, B1.
Now, control copy.
So I'm supposed to be showing
you how easy it is to do this,
but--all right,
so anyway that's it.
So if you see for each number
here I've got the payments for
every year and I've discounted
them by taking this internal
rate of return,
and now I just have to sum all
this.
Equals sum parenthesis.
Oh shit.
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: I'm trying to sum
it, you're right.
So here equals,
I want to sum all these.
So what did I do wrong?
Student: C1 colon C10.
Prof: C1 colon C10,
that's what I thought I did,
but obviously I didn't.
Good, and now we can do this
and square it.
So that's the thing I want to
minimize, and so now I'm going
to Tools, Solver,
Min, C12 by concentrating on
this number, and solve.
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: All right,
what did I do?
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: Here's the sum,
here's the...
Student: The original
price.
Prof: Oh,
the original price.
Ah ha!
Thank you very much.
So we need the original price
of 105.
Very good, so I see that
preparing this would have
helped.
So here's the sum.
So we just summed all these
things, and here we're going
to--so we're summing those,
right?
So I summed all these and then
I've got the original price 105
enter.
Now we'll add equals this plus
this.
Student:
<<overlapping
conversation>>
Prof: You're right,
this minus that.
And now we want to square this,
equals up squared enter and now
we'll do Solver.
Hopefully there isn't another
mistake.
So Tools, Solver,
so I want that times E1.
Oh, that's very bad.
Anyway, you can solve it using
Solver and it's extremely simple
to do, and a child could learn
how to do it.
So we get Solver and we solve
all this, and you should be able
to use Excel with no problem at
all.
So the question is what are the
relationships between the
current yield and the yield to
maturity, and suppose there's
some actual interest rate.
So there's an actual market
interest rate of,
say, 6 percent or something.
So those are the things that we
want to sort out now in the next
five minutes.
So let me go back to the notes
and we'll re-ask all the
questions here.
You can see that's Solver.
I've broken Solver.
Suppose that there were an
actual interest rate in the
economy and our bond,
the bond that was 7,7,
7,107, if the actual interest
rate was,
say, 6 percent the price of the
bond would be more than 100.
So some price which will be the
present value will be greater
than 100,
obviously, because it's
paying--if the interest rate's
only 6 percent this is giving
you more than 100.
Now, the current yield is 7
over the present value,
exactly analogous to what he
said.
So if someone calls you on the
phone,
you haven't gotten these calls
yet,
but when you get older you'll
get--they're screened now,
so it's harder to get these,
but it used to be a few years
ago you'd get called on the
phone quite often and somebody
would say he's running a bond
fund,
and the bond fund is really
doing great,
and he wants to tell you that
the bonds they have in the fund
last year paid a current yield
of 7 over the present value
which is much bigger than the
interest rate of 6 percent,
and therefore you should buy
his bonds.
Now, what can you say about
that?
Suppose somebody tells you
there's a market price for the
bonds,
which we know is the present
value at the interest rate of 6
percent,
and he tells you that,
"Look,
look at the market value I got
last year,
the yield I got;
the current yield I got on
these bonds.
The present value was some
number bigger than 100,
but I take 7 over the present
value and I get something bigger
than 6 percent.
At your bank you're only
getting 6 percent,
so therefore you should invest
in my fund."
Is that a good argument to
invest in his fund?
Why not?
Now, this bond is called a
premium bond because the price
is bigger than the face,
and a discount bond means the
price is less than the face,
and a par bond,
the price equals the face.
So just because a bond pays a
coupon of 7--
it may be when the bond was
issued everybody thought the
interest rate was going to be 7
percent forever,
so that's why they picked a
coupon of 7 so that the price
when they first issued it would
be equal to its face value.
But maybe the next day,
so it's still a 10-year bond,
practically no time has
changed, but unexpectedly the
interest rates fell to 6
percent.
If you take the same coupon
bond paying 7 all the time at 6
percent interest its price is
obviously going to go up in the
market because everybody is
going to discount the 7s,
not at 7 percent,
but at 6 percent and get a
number that's bigger than 100.
So you're going to have to pay
more for the bond because the
present value's higher.
However, people who now will
try and market the bond they're
going to tell you,
"Well, look at the market
price," whatever the market
price is.
So the current yield is the
market price.
They'll say,
"Look at the market price.
This is what we bought the
bonds for.
I'm a fund.
I went out and bought these
bonds.
Look at the price I paid and I
got 7 dollars for these bonds
this year in income and 7 over
the market price of the bond is
bigger than 6 percent,
so I was doing a great job.
You should invest in my
fund."
So, that can't be a correct
thing to say or a persuasive
thing to say,
because the market price
reflected the fact that the
interest rates were 6 percent.
Everybody was properly
computing the present value,
and let's say the market price
was equal to the present value,
the present value would indeed
be greater than 100 and in fact
the current yield would be more
than the interest rate of 6
percent.
So why is that?
So, theorem,
if market price equals present
value at a going interest rate
then the current yield on a
premium bond is always greater
than the interest rate.
So why is that?
So in this case,
if I hadn't screwed up the
Excel we would have calculated
the present value.
So 7,7, 7,107 there's only a 6
percent interest.
So everybody taught by Irving
Fisher computes the new present
value which of course is bigger
than 100 and that's the market
price.
Some unscrupulous salesman
starts a fund,
buys the bond for whatever this
present value,
the market price is,
then goes out to a bunch of
clients,
potential clients,
investors, and says,
"Look, my very first year
in business I spent a little
more than 100 dollars and I got
7 dollars as a coupon and 7 over
this little more than 100 is
giving me at current yield
that's more than 6 percent.
I beat the interest rate.
You should invest in me,
and by the way,
I'll charge you a little fee to
do that because I'm doing so
great."
Now, that's always going to be
the case so it has to be that he
really hasn't accomplished
anything at all.
So why is it easy to see that
whenever I computed the present
value it was going to have to be
more than--
this current yield would always
be more than 6 percent.
How do I know that?
Yep?
Student: Because of the
face value that's going to be at
the end at maturity isn't going
to reflect that increased
interest or relatively higher
interest.
It's going to be the original
face value.
Prof: Exactly.
So let's say,
to keep this simpler,
let's suppose these were 10s
everywhere, and the interest
rate went down to 5 percent.
Now, what's going to be the
present value of this bond?
It's not going to be 200, right?
If the bond paid 10,10,
210, suppose I have something
paying 10-10-10 and 110,
and the coupon is 5 percent.
The present value is going to
be less than 200.
The coupon is always double the
interest rate,
so it looks like that's what
you'd get if you had 200
dollars,
but at the end,
as he's saying,
you're only going to get 110
and not 210.
So this present value of this
thing has to be less than 200.
So if you double the coupon--if
you halve the interest rate,
the interest rate was
originally 10 percent,
if you cut the interest rate in
half to 5 percent it looks like
your annual coupon is double the
interest rate,
but at the end you don't get
principal that's double the
original principal.
All you did was
double--relative to the interest
rate of 5 percent,
the coupon's twice as big as
you normally expect,
but the face isn't.
So therefore,
this has to be worth less than
200.
If it were 200 at 5 percent it
would give you 10,
10,10, 10,10,
210, but this gives you 10,
10,10, 110, so obviously the
present value is less than 200,
but therefore 10 over something
less than 200 is going to be
more than 5 percent.
So that's his intuitive proof,
which is the essence of the
thing,
that if ever you have a coupon
bond that's a premium bond then
the current yield is always
above the interest rate.
So you can always advertise it
as having a spectacular current
yield when in fact it's just
priced perfectly fairly.
So I'm going to just continue
this story of what's the right
way to measure things and how
you can get confused by
measuring the wrong way next
class.